one of the globe's most crucial
commodities going up in smoke the result
of twin drone strikes at the heart of
Saudi Arabia's oil industry state media
say the fires that erupted after
Saturday's attacks were quickly brought
into control but officials say that
production at the ab cake oil processing
facility the largest in the world and
the caress oilfield the country's
second-biggest has been temporarily
suspended there are fears of how this
might affect world markets with Saudi
Arabia responsible for about a tenth of
the world's oil output these strikes
have effectively cut five percent of
global supply overnight for over four
years now reott has been involved in a
proxy war with Iran in Yemen the
country's Houthi rebels who are backed
by Tehran have claimed responsibility
for the attacks and vowed more we
promised the Saudi regime that our
coming operations will only grow wider
and will be more painful than before
so long as their aggression and blockade
continues but Washington is pointing the
finger at Iran US Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo said on Twitter that there
was no evidence the attacks had come
from Yemen well for more on the story
I'm joined here in the studio by
Abdullah Nagamani he's a freelance Saudi
journalist based here in Berlin thank
you so much for coming in today
now we've been hearing that the Houthi
rebels are claiming responsibility for
the attacks on the Saudi oil
installations why did they choose to
attack now well well that's what we hear
from one side the ho t the ho these are
claiming that they they made it while
the u.s. they have confirmation from my
quite view that the Iranian had made it
and there is like clash between these
three I mean Houthis and Iran one side
and the United States is blaming Iran
while Saudi government is still like
they did not really mention who made it
so far but they are ensuring I mean the
Saudi government insuring trying to
ensure the world that the oil sub norm
the oil is going to continue within 48
hours
after they lost like the half of it
after this attack however there is a
small piece that we read that in the qat
newspaper and I don't know why the
agencies they did not really have looked
at it so a Kuwaiti newspaper has
excludes a piece of news that they
recorded and reported there is a drone
just hour before this attack was
violating the Kuwaiti airspace and they
came from from that side so it's like in
theory it's more that drone came from
north of Saudi Arabia and northeast from
Saudi Arabia which is not from Houthi
sighs Houthis US based in the south of
Saudi Arabia so if we can read that so
it's it's more coming from other sites
so we can believe more the u.s. it's
still conflicting reports about who in
fact is behind it you mentioned it
already so half of the oil production of
the state or in owned oil company Aramco
has been affected but what does this
tell us about how vulnerable Saudi oil
installations are it's not a matter of
the facilities it's more matter of the
national security so if we talk here
it's like we talk about the Middle East
tension and the matter of Technology and
how the drones can be like violate their
space of other countries because it's
really hard to to shoot these things
because they just fly on there like
lower level and it has it has its own
say in the coming tension in Saudi
Arabia this is not the first time the
oil facilities has been targeted in
Saudi Arabia this year if we come back
in May 2000 19 that happened but was
very limited damage but this one is it
seems big it does indeed
and I mean you say this isn't the first
time but it's certainly a very very
major attack what kind of an impact is
it going to have on a global scale
that's what we are waiting for because
it's Sunday now it's it's
and so the oil market is not hopping yet
so we are waiting for tomorrow and also
I'm curious about the Saudi reaction and
I'm following the news
what's that Saudi Arabia and saw the
government on the political level what
they would react
what's the investigation is going to say
who's who made it because it's already
that and it's not really affecting the
Saudi Arabia only or the region it's
affecting the world so it's like we are
following the really continuing in the
news and we should be close to the news
what's going on and in that region all
right
I'm Jamal Olga Bonnie thank you so much
for coming into the studio with your
insights thanks for having me